so we have the next speaker who needs
very little introduction a lot of us
learned RL from reading his lecture
notes and books and articles so Java
speciali is uh his his like two places
right now I guess one in University of
Alberta and one Google deep mine and
he's going to talk about
multi-criteria mdps today I look forward
to it
um
right
um
let's get started
how many people here know about
this multi-clicker mdps uh constraint
mdps
okay so I I do a short introduction
about those and uh
basically the purpose is to discuss
whether these uh solving these is harder
or not and solving mdps uh in a very
practical narrow setting uh and so I I
wouldn't venture to
jump into the conclusion that in general
you can expect that the results are
going to hold
uh for more general settings but at
least in these network settings I think
that we found something quite
interesting
um
so first the standard framework for
reinforcement learning is that you have
maybe an agent of brain it interacts
with an unknown environment sending
actions to it and receiving States and
rewards from it and the call is to
design uh some brain for this agents
such that whatever environment is going
to face it can maximize the potassium of
expected uh discounted rewards in this
case I'm going to assume this content
and so you have this little gamma Factor
here uh comma is a discount Factory it's
between zero and one
and uh future rewards rewards received
later uh a discounted uh by raising this
is contracted to a higher part so that
means that there are exponentially less
important if you would plug in a reward
of one this series converges and the
limit is 1 over 1 minus comma which also
corresponds to you can think about that
as the effective Horizon that uh that
the planet needs to look look ahead uh
to plan for good actions because beyond
that Horizon nothing really matters
because things are so small
okay
um
so the difference to the standard uh
setting uh that I'm going to consider uh
today is that instead of having one
reward function we're going to have at
least 20 watt functions I'm gonna keep
it simple so we are going to have
exactly two reward functions
one reward function I call it a task
keyword you want to maximize it as usual
the other reward is kind of like a
constraint revoice so that's why it's
called the C it's kind of confusing you
might think that it's a cost but it's
not a cost it's still a reward so you're
you're summing up these constant rewards
in a discounted fashion take expectation
in the usual way and you want to ensure
that this constant reward is high enough
in the past that you're solving so
that's the formulation this is called
constraint mdps and you can motivate
constraint mdps in various ways uh
generally it is just that sometimes it's
more convenient to see the problems that
constantly in a constant formulation
than uh to state it as a pure
optimization formulation uh it kind of
broadens uh the class of problems that
we can describe
um and that
leads to uh my next slide which is uh
about a paper done by my excellent
colleagues at deepmind recently appeared
in the GI Channel and they're arguing
that a single reward should be enough
for everything so this goes into the
face of that because here I'm saying
that well
some problems are just going to be much
easier to state if you have two rewards
uh so maybe under some conditions you
could reformulate things in such a way
that you can get away with a single
reward but in general there's certainly
not a case for example it's really I and
we will see that it's really easy to
come up with examples where uh the
optimal policy for this constraint
formulation needs randomized Polaris uh
for the classic formulation when you
have a single reward there is absolutely
no need to randomize ever
so the class of optimal policies is what
a different uh so clearly uh there is uh
a discrepancy here but uh
the question is uh
to me whether it's it's not whether a
single reward is enough but maybe I I
would ask a question in such a way that
developing algorithms for the single
reward case is enough to handle maybe
this more complicated cases and we will
see today that this is kind of like
really intriguing question
um so is there a non-trivial cost to be
paid for example if you if you're
debating from the single reward
formulation and secondly whether the
algorithms that you are developing for
the single reward case are going to
be extendable uh to this case uh and uh
yeah it's it's kind of very curious
all right so uh this is just uh the
symbols that I'm going to use through
the talk uh so I will I promise that I
will keep everything super simple so
we'll have finitely many states finitely
many actions no generalization with
functional approximation no monkey
business with that keeping it super
simple uh so you have as States a
actions they are identified with
integers let's say uh between 1 and S
and one and a and uh you have rewards
and for most of the talk I'm going to
assume that uh the vbf planner and and
the planner is going to be given the
rewards ahead of time but the planner is
not going to know the state transitions
the state transitions describe this
markovian Dynamics uh of how the state
transists from a state to an extent
given that the agent is taking some
action
and in this formulation uh because we
are talking about a constraint
formulation is going to be important
that we will have an initial State
distribution a state distribution over
the initial state so every time uh we
are evaluating a policy which uh for our
purposes it's enough to think that it's
it's just a map from states to actions
maybe it should be stochastic it's uh
like you need distributions of reactions
uh at least uh so whenever you have a
it's such a policy uh you roll out from
this the initial State chosen from row
and then following the policy that
generates a sequence of states and
actions you receive the rewards along
the way you discount them send them up
take expectation
um and uh the goal uh in standard mdps
is just to maximize uh this and and this
can be done regardless of the initial
State distribution there exists policies
as stationary deterministic policies for
that matter uh which achieve the best
possible this is called a value uh at
every state just single policy and
um
for notation uh so since we're gonna
change the reward function and division
from the standard Innovation notation is
that I'm going to put the reward in the
index of the value function so that's
going to be important
um and uh so One More Concept an Epson
optimal policies any policy that comes
Epsilon close to the optimal value at
every state
okay so this is standard just to recap
notation
um and if if you know everything then
the iteration policy iteration linear
programming all of these uh excellent
tools uh can be used to find a policy uh
and avoid an exponential cause that you
would encounter if you just try to
enumerate all deterministic places
all right so let's start with
programming uh so in the constant
formulation you have this constraining
reward function which also takes values
in zero and one and
recycling the notation that we had
before you can just very constantly lie
the problem as maximizing the value
given an initial State under the task
reward subject to constraint and the
value that is generated by the
constraining reward function
so uh the planner is going to be given
this uh B and uh maybe it's it's given
this row and it's given C and R but
maybe it's not going to know the uh the
transition properties and and we're
going to be interested in how many
samples you need to generate uh from the
model in order to be able to to solve
this this problem if you knew everything
uh then you can reformulate this and and
write this as an LP you just write the
discounted State occupancy measures and
the value uh these values are just uh
the reward integrated with respect to
this discounted State occupancy measure
this is also similar to that so those
are linear in this discounted State
occupancy measures uh and these measures
live in a very nice bodytope so you can
optimize this over over this positive
polytop using linear programming and
from that you you can just like
marginalize uh with respect to the uh
the actions and read out of policies
that that's how people would normally
think about solving a problem like this
and uh so in the talk I'm going to make
this feasibility assumption uh without
me without which uh there is no life uh
uh just have to assume that
this constraint can be satisfied by some
policies so in other words B is not too
high right so if you just want to
maximize the constraining reward
function the maximum value that you
could achieve is the best policy that
doesn't care about the task reward just
cares about the constraining reward
would actually be and that is a positive
Gap there
okay I'm imagining the option for this
is no longer stationary the Optima
policy can be a stationary policy but it
will be randomizing if you think about
what the lp solution does okay so you
would need to prove that okay like that
that's the case but uh if if you are
inviting this if you're thinking about
trust stationary policy system you can
write this with discounted occupancy but
you can go beyond stationary you can go
to markovian policies they have the same
state occupancy measures as the uh as
the stationary Mark of importances so
it's all fine right so you can just
think about this as the RP and then from
that you will see that uh you can always
find a Stationary markovian policy and
that is even ethereum that says that the
number of states at which you have to
randomize something like that is
dependent on how many constraints you're
gonna have and so forth so in this case
it's one
like how large are these LP and how do
you solve this LP right right so I'm
dealing with a toy situation here uh so
I'm going to postpone anything related
to
uh going Beyond really small state
action spaces where you could animate
everything
um and and that's absolutely not
practical right like that's not how you
should be thinking about these things uh
but people would do normally is that
they would throw in functional
approximation here approximate the value
functions using some features neural
networks or whatnot and then you can
scale up but that's exactly what I'm not
going to talk about today and I don't
even know uh what channel is from what
I'm going to talk about today so this is
a least practical talk ever
yeah the the reason you do this is
because uh
in the past we have seen that whatever
intuition you're gaining and studying a
city problem like this
a lot of it transfers so whenever you
can push things to work with function
approximation it kind of is rooted in
ideas of of City problems like this
but I have no better reason than this to
study this problem
on every sample part the cost has to be
at least three right is it a verse no
but then it's just when you're
guaranteed through this because now it's
just a constraint so
is much bigger sure but it's not going
to randomize so I guess maybe just a
philosophical question why sort of
Mark's expectation subject to
expectation right okay so that's a very
good question why pick this formulation
as opposed to the million other
constraint formulations
it's the simplest one
that comes first and like it's classical
I'm not saying that this is the best
Union to every of everyone's practical
problems it certainly does make sense
like on the average the constraining
river needs to exceed something it's
like a soft constraint because you are
averaging over those closely rewards as
well right like it's not even that hard
version of it you expected the hard
version requires even more prior
knowledge it's going to be harder to
solve so it's like this is the smallest
deviation from Mbps you can imagine
it's like a multi-objective and maybe
which you're making one objective that's
right like what it's it's like you have
two objectives that may be conflicting
and then like if you wanted to throw the
whole body at the front then you could
sleep through b and like trying to do
that and then this doesn't quite explain
why this formulation uh this is one of
the foreign
uh
okay
anyways excellent questions uh just not
going to answer that
all right so this is the sample
complexity of planning uh so this this
is the city poem model uh you have the
full State action space given to you and
uh it's all enumerated and you can
choose any state action and you will get
a transition uh from the underlying
kernel probably the kernel you see the
next state randomly sampled from that
and then you ask if uh a planner needs
to to solve one of these problems and
then I'm going to have two versions of
this problems
um then how many samples are we going to
need
um and um
yeah this this is the so the generative
model is hugely unrealistic uh
and we've worked really hard on the mdp
setting to get away from it and and
there is a lot of literature on it but
if you can't do something on the
generative setting or you find that
something is already hard in a
generative setting it's gonna be even
harder under the more general settings
so it's kind of like a just a simple
starting point so what are the two
settings that we're going to consider uh
so in one setting IO constraint
violation uh of of size Epsilon
and in the other setting no constant
violation is uh is a load maybe the
justification for that is that like come
on like if you set your mind on having a
constraint and like just keep it like
why why change it right like otherwise
you can just like shift it up I mean
that comes the question of like if you
shift it up by by Epsilon uh then maybe
you're exceeding the best possible
reward that you could get and like you
will get in trouble so when you are in
this uh small slitter Gap and then the
Epsilon is is large compared to the
Slater Gap then it's kind of like a an
interesting scenario there right
then it will be interesting to see how
things interact uh if you have this
strict constraint
all right so
um is everything clear
all right so what do we know about this
uh problem setting for MVPs uh there's
been a long line of research uh starting
with this paper from 1999 uh and then uh
Muhammad Azad and wonderful co-workers
had some paper in 2013 and then other
papers uh came along and everything got
refined and and now we have matching low
and upper bonds uh finally after I don't
know
22 years of research on Tumblr MVPs in
the generative setting uh matching low
and upper bounds uh the sample
complexity of planning is uh scaling
linearly with the number of states the
actions
Horizon and uh as usual in in
statistical learning skills inverted
with the square of the desired Precision
right so that that part everyone uh
immediately understands maybe this one
like the lower Bond it's easy to
understand that every state action pad
you need to gain some information the
question is whether in the upper Bond
why you're not seeing an S squared
s squared a is would be the the size of
the transition probability Matrix uh and
and we're getting away uh
um with linear dependence on S uh so
that's a that's a much more uh dedicated
question and we're going to talk about
that a little bit so that's not trivial
to get uh the cubic dependence on on the
effective Horizon just comes from
studying the sensitivity of the value
function to the transition structure you
write some silly example you take some
derivatives and you see this cubic
dependence popping out so it's like a
sensitive if you don't know some
Transitions and you uh jitted them a
little the way you can jump around
cubicle
um with the effective Horizon
um so the Precision that that you're
gonna need is a
appropriately uh needs to be uh
tightened uh to deal with this uh
skating up
so an MVP is of course a special case of
a constant mdp uh so uh immediately get
a lower Bond uh
that the cmdp learning problem is at
least as hard as the mdp learning
problem
and and the question is that is is it
any harder or is it maybe the same uh
and so the this uh we are not the first
one to ask this question there's been a
lot of algorithms designed and then
people were getting better and better
results and the state of Beyond before
or paper was was something like this uh
there's like 20 of different papers but
this is kind of like taking the price at
the moment or we're taking the price at
the moment so uh
this paper allows constraint violation
and gets an upper bond that scares
quadratically with the number of states
uh otherwise the scaling looks fine okay
so
that's maybe not idea uh
so another paper allowing constraint
violation uh gasoline are scaling with
number of states but uh skiers uh is the
fifth bar of the Horizon so what's going
on uh then there is a paper by by it or
L and they were updating and updating
and in the most recent version of the
paper if you rewrite it with their
notation and normalization what you get
is that you get leaders getting with the
number of states and number of actions
but you get a first part skating uh with
the effective Horizon and the slaughter
constraint uh or Slater I don't know
Slater constraint appears
in this fashion and this is for the
three constraints setting
and and for the non-stick constraint
setting I think that they also have a
result we where where also uh the
dependence on on the horizon is is
sub-optimal
okay
uh so this is the state of the act so
what's going on is this really necessary
that we have this deviation from the
mdps or not
um and so first of all uh where is this
dependence and the slaughter translator
constraint comes in uh so we can
consider very very uh even simpler
problem than what we looked before so
just ban it uh you have a single state I
love Bandits and uh
the task reward is either one or zero if
you're taking one of the actions first
action you get a task about a fun
out of God otherwise you get task reward
of zero so obviously the first action is
what you want to take as often as you
you you can
but there is a constraining reward and
the concerning reward goes the other way
and it's like you get less reward if
you're taking the first action and
actually you get less reward than the
constraint the threshold that you have
is B so if you would always just take
this action you wouldn't satisfy the
constraint so you have to balance
between taking this action and the other
action and it's this uh is nicely set up
in a symmetric fashion just for the sake
of keeping the example very simple such
that to me the constraint you have to
randomize this equal probability between
the two uh choices then you're just
meeting the constraint and of course
that's maximize this uh the task reward
as well so
good
you get back to the same thing same
state every time step so every round is
the same as all the previous rounds so
it doesn't matter the very discounting
or not it's just a banner
yeah okay so let's say gamma is there in
this case so that yeah I guess it's just
like I just want to do Bandits I my
heart is still with the bandits
yeah good catch uh so here we said gamma
to zero that's the simplest explanation
uh because otherwise yeah like the B
should be scared and everything should
be scared but everything
all right
um and so now the question is uh so what
happens when you're uh when you're
getting uh noisy information
uh when you need to interact with this
generative model you're going to have
estimation errors and so let's imagine
that in this case you are estimating
this uh constraint reward and you have
an error of you and if you haven't had
or a few and you're just like planning
as if that was a true reward we can like
you know like just to gain some
intuition uh we can look at how uh the
value how the policy is going to change
so uh so let's imagine that instead of
uh C1 which is B minus X the revert that
we are working is is C1 plus u which is
B minus X plus uh so if U is positive
then C1 is a little bit uh higher
If U is negative then C1 is a little bit
lower if C1 is a little bit higher then
that means that we can put a little bit
more probability on this action we're
going to be happier if U is negative
then we have to put a little bit less
probability on this action and we are
going to be less happy about the task
reward
and uh ultimately you can work out what
what the optimized solution is and you
will find that the Optimus solution is
roughly one-half plus u so that's the
the error in estimating that the
constraining reward divided by 4X
and uh so the sensitivity to the error
is inversely proportional to X and and
what is X here well X is just the rule
that you have between your constraint
and the maximum possible value that you
could get so that's exactly the
slaughter constraint right so you see
that because you have this constraint if
you're misestimating things in the
constraint
you're going to pay in proportion to the
room that you had in satisfying the
constraint which is uh invently
proportional to that
so the slaughter constraint or slitter
constraint is is something that we
expect to see in the bonds if you need
to keep uh the uh the constraint right
so this this kind of explains uh the
presence of the slaughter constraint uh
or slit a constraint I will never learn
it
and lo and behold uh you can refine this
argument you can come up with uh some
more or less standard construction so
take the mdp lower bound construction
modify it a little bit so that you are
mostly playing with the constraint
Rewards and you can prove that no
algorithm can get away with less than S
A times and you see that the Horizon
blows up to the fifth bar
and otherwise you have the usual terms
except that the Slater constraint
appears inversely as a kind of expected
from given the previous slide
all right uh
and uh the explanation for all of this
is that uh so the sensitive sensitivity
to uh misestimating the constraint uh
leads to that you need to estimate the
constant constant reward rated
quantities up to a higher accuracy
that's guessed like this and then that's
the source for the extra factor of 2 in
the effective Horizon uh because this
one minus gamma is just like the inverse
of the Horizon uh and uh also the source
of the Slater constraint appearing in a
bond spread
so that's a straight straight
constraints no you do not allow the
violation here yeah here there is no
constant violation a lot if concept
violation is a lot uh then we're still
hoping that maybe it's not worse than
mdp so uh so the first thing that we
were doing is that we wanted to
understand the Penance of this slitter
constraint and how exactly things should
be behaving on on the horizon but you
sort of
bully like
conjecture that this is going to be
important only when you have strict
constraints
of the books of the earlier papers they
had eight to the four that's really
speak so they're wrong or they're
different or
no everything is fine because the first
two papers uh they allowed constraint
violation
uh so they're not yeah like
this was not the case when we found some
bugs in some papers
foreign
because what happened is that they
started to normalize sink such that the
values are in the zero one range and
then that discuss everything yeah that's
an extra It's that or something
and so if you if you add that H squared
and you get the H to the sixth yeah
yeah that's that's that's that's correct
like I need to correct my slides it's h
to the six
all right
um
all right so so we see that that paper
almost got it right except that that is
an extra uh h factor
okay
um so the next task is to get some
matching upper bonds and uh
or good old friend is just a plugin
approach right uh so what works in mdp
should work in cmdps what works in mdps
is that at each state action pair you
get the the same number of samples uh
there's no expiration issue you just get
like some uniformly good information at
all the state action Pairs and then you
just compute uh the empirical uh
an empirical estimate of the transition
oh what is that okay
um just basically counting Transitions
and uh and you you solve the resulting
mdp and uh if you do that then after 20
years of work you can prove that you can
match the floor Bond
um so we saw that uh maybe the same
thing is gonna like it would be
beautiful it wouldn't be this would be
the simplest approach uh if it worked
and this is the first thing we tried and
we failed at it like we we can't prove
that this works for a number of reasons
and and I'm very curious whether other
people will be able to to prove that
this works or maybe there is some reason
this shouldn't work so what am I talking
about like what is the plugin server
like any method that solves the
empirical mdp up to an Epsilon accuracy
uh so take your favorite app solver or
whatever you read all this policy and
then you would need to prove that it
didn't matter how you arrived at this
policy it's Epsilon optimal
you should be good and and like there is
a strong feeling that this should be
true that like if
if the plug-in method doesn't get it
like why would any specific method get
it it's like but we will see later okay
A little spoiler or there that we do
have some other methods for which we can
get some nice positive results
that we couldn't prove for for this
simple plugin approach uh so why what
what are the problems so what one
problem is that okay if you just solve
without thinking much then the the
policy that you read out might be
infeasible uh so you have to
set up things in such a way that the
constraint is uh the constant threshold
is modified a little bit maybe increase
it by an Epsilon
um or you increase the Precision a
little bit so to make sure that the
empirically Optima what is any Epsilon
optimal policy that uh that solves the
empirical constraint mdp is going to be
feasible for the original Mbps file
that you can take care of but then the
other problem is that normally what we
can do is that we can control the
deviation uh between the value functions
of for a fixed policy
or they can also do that control the
deviation between uh the optimal value
function between the empirical mdp and
and the true MVP uh but here what we are
we we have is that we have a random
policy that we read out and then we need
to control
well okay there should be a hat over
there uh the deviation between uh the
value of it in the empirical uh
mdp versus the true mdp and of course
people like this is the essence of the
problem in the mdp setting as well so
people are being quite busy uh trying to
figure out how to do these things
um but usually what people end up doing
is that you use some sort of bammon
equation uh rely on optimal value
functions uh and so forth but if you
solve this let's say this in LP then
okay like you do have
bam on equations for the individual
policies but not for the Optima like the
optimal value function per se doesn't
it's it's not a thing anymore right
because it's like you just have this
this policy that is not optimal for the
task reward it's it's not optimal maybe
for anything you just got it and like
okay what are you gonna do with it uh
uh you could try to apply Union bonds uh
over all the policies but that's what
leads to the sub-optimal scaling with
the number of states for example or or
other quantities
um so long story short
you can't make this work
so
um then uh we had to go back to the
drawing board and we had to rethink our
strategy and after this much failure we
realized that the only way we will be
able to control the terms that we need
to control is if we are relying on mdp
like solving mdps
and so now uh how do you reduce solving
a cmdp to solving uh maybe not one mdp
but a series of mdps we have seen this
in previous talks uh similar similar
things right like you you cut you you do
the long-ranchi and uh and you have
maximum formulation and if you solve the
maximum formulation in an iterative
fashion where your uh uh playing a best
response to uh some long-ranchien that
you're updating with I don't know this
gradient is sent uh then
then you come up with this iterative
method
um and the nice thing that happens here
is that the Lang ranchien is combining
the value functions
are under the task reward and the
constraining reward of a policy and this
is linear in the rewards right so you
can just write this
as the value function underlying the
linearly combined Rewards so you can
push everything into the index there and
this is just solving an mdp now right so
in every step we need to solve an mdp
we're not happy about that that like we
don't care but we can solve our piece
that's not the problem it's not
numerical optimization issue it's a
statistical issue we are happy about
solving MEPS because we know how to
control
uh the statistical error of getting
right the solution of mdps
right the sample complexity we have very
refined tools for dealing with that
and so that's those are the tools that
we want to to use to control these
deviations now but we have a number of
other issues that we have to take care
we have a bunch of these policies uh and
I mean like there are some stability
issues and so forth uh
it turns out
not in pie but but you don't really need
that
you don't need it
you can always go to the occupancy
measures if you already cared about that
but but you don't need it like the best
Lambda may not need
that is a term that says that it does
get and the way to imagine that is that
the occupancy measures a corresponding
one-to-one with the policies
so the policy is just an indexing into
the occupancy space and an occupancy
base you have nice complexity uh
and you have zero Duality to get there
so you have to say yeah so it's just
like the bottom maturization is this
inconvenient parametrization of the
optimization problem but it's
it looks like as if you didn't have it
but you do that
exists no
it doesn't mean that so for any fixed
Lambda there is
no no so you can't flip the mean and the
max without making it
yeah yeah so if you if you're flipping
them in the next then the max will be
over a mixture policies
no the mixture policies you're good
right like that's the convex space so
even if I give you the opponent I'm just
trying
you need to randomize yeah we had the
example that I showed
that without randomization in hunger
I guess technically you should one
Optimus Prime you're saying that also
shows that rules out any non-plantalized
optimal products these rules are right
to The Exchange like to close the gap
you need to make it
make that world people you're going to
that space
so it may be confusing what I'm saying
uh so that there is no Duality Gap
doesn't mean that you complete the mean
and back say you have to say bye here
that's not true
foreign
could very well be a deterministic
policy which is not
baby related question is just is the
final thing you output from this
algorithm it's not going to be like Pi
hat being T right it's getting up some
mixtures it's just a mixture yeah
all right yeah it's like taking the
average of all of these places
and that's a nature policy that you're
output so we effectively like searching
the space of nature called the system
uh uh you can find a mixture is not too
many components it's like next slide
that's absolutely
does that make sense
so in particular last iterate uh
conversion I mean you can't disappear
this rules out there yeah the last trick
can very well be deterministic so
there's no way you can do anything like
that
you could try to come up with stochastic
policies along the way and maybe you
could have lots of credit promotions
there but that's a different story we
were absolutely not doing that this is
just plain best results
these policies could be different
actually we want that to be
deterministic this makes our life easier
all right okay
um all right so some sanity check uh
the area term actually solves the cmdp
uh so that's the first thing uh you
don't need too many iterates
uh to solve the cmdp so if you want an
Epsilon optimized solution
uh with some relaxation of the
constraint I mean like you can increase
this by this and then you
the constant exactly match uh
then you don't have you don't need too
many iterates and then you can you can
solve this argument of the cmdp the
empiric calcium so this doesn't tell us
that we are solving the original entity
uh up to any accuracy right it just asks
you that this optimization algorithm is
not silly
like we we just wanted to have some way
of solving the cmdp where we can talk
about that the policies that we we uh we
have we came up with along the way
underly
some mdp with some reward function there
are optimal policies in some mdps with
some reward functions yes
under this statement depends on the
gender issues in the previous night so
in the projection uh you need to so
there are two things here and there are
kind of fine details and I hope to uh
just uh
conveniently not to talk about them but
since you're asking uh so you need to
estimate the larger value the slitter
constraint should take and I think that
that will be uh something with the
effective Horizon
and you can prove that divided by the
slit that constraints I think
no to estimate the slitter constant
under feasibility it's not really a
problem you can have a doubling
algorithm that makes a guess and then
like the the gas is the largest liter
constant possible that's the effective
Horizon you have it you half it you have
it and then you keep checking whether by
just solving the NDP uh for the
constraining reward whether that's later
constraint uh gas was correct or not and
this is going to stop as soon as you are
below the actions with the constraint by
a factor of two so you can do that
effectively
um
so yeah like eventually in this
algorithm you need to choose a bunch of
parameters like the Ito and uh I didn't
talk about this uh later on maybe we can
return to that we are going to do some
running as well of this language
multipliers uh to a grid
um
to uh
to prevent some nasty things happening
um basically we don't want too many unit
bonds
so that's like put an ad on the
reasonable range of the language and
multipliers that's fine enough do the
rounding you're not going to introduce
errors that are too big so you might
have said this already but in the lower
bound setting you had a strict
constraint but here is non-strict order
am I missing something it's both uh
we're gonna at the end of the day the
same algorithm can be used uh to uh to
install both settings uh I didn't tell
you but here we have B prime minister of
B so to satisfy the three constraint
we're gonna take B Prime slightly bigger
than b
[Music]
well that was the example with the
sensitivity right like if the slaughter
constant is pretty smaller than uh
yes
[Music]
all right
or can you
do
something
exactly
let's keep asking this question I have
no idea
so I hate it so much I love it
uh discrimination of something I did
down below okay
what we did was we just took the extra
neck found the optical doors
videos
something like that
so what exactly so just try to directly
find Optimal Lambda okay
well we don't have the Machinery to call
uh to control
uh the value Adder on the Privacy divide
unless we are solving MVPs so the
solving the finding solving that problem
foreign
policies like it's not a linear approach
I mean this is not a computational issue
at all like we're just making our life
Much Higher by coming up is an iterative
formulation rather than just saying that
solve is happy with whatever way you get
some empirically optimal language and
you prove some stability results you can
do that before trying to do that but at
the end of the day we need to control
the statistical accuracy of the policy
that we read out
and then trying to do that in software
all these extra factors of like an extra
aspect to an extra H Vector if you're
not careful about these things and we
were not able to do things
like okay so you will see some slide but
I will uncover the magic of using MVPs
and like that will explain to a large
degree
why choose this way
uh
I'm sick so this this algorithm is only
motivated
because we can analyze it and get
optimal results
okay but you would not do the Lambda
through the screen okay so you could
just like solve for every value of the
create and like yeah I think that that's
first
I think that that yeah
like if there's any monotonicity you
could be
[Music]
foreign
so we are solving mdps with with some
Rewards
where the land wrench multiplier comes
from a grid
and so we have this finitely many
choices for the reward function we are
just solving all those empirical mdps
and you can you can feel that that the
union bond is not a problem
and then uh we want to argue about these
deviations uh and and notice what's
what's uh again like something uh
difference happening then in the mdp
case we're solving an mdp for a reward
that includes
the constraining reward and then we are
looking at the value functions not for
that
but the reward without the language and
the language is set to zero
so we have that Gap that we also need to
cover otherwise you could just like use
mdp techniques
and you would be done
um and okay so in like the general uh
look at this is that you have some
Authority words and you have some beta
rewards and you're solving the optimal
body Center off rewards and then you
want to argue about value functions and
the beta reports
and can you do this
um
and long story short uh well I have uh I
don't know I think three minutes is
hopefully going to be enough uh that
there is all this wonderful work that
was done in the empty literature and you
can kind of adapt it so the first work
is uh by chandli uh and others uh from
Europe's uh 2020
uh they have this this theorem that says
that this division of that that is of
interest for us can be controlled for a
data dependent policy arbitrary data
dependent policy as long as some
benchtein type of inequality horse here
n is the number of samples so it's like
you have a variance term and you have a
faster term and there are some uh value
functions which are defined in some
complicated fashion don't don't bother
about that they
are important thing about this though is
that this bench same type of
inequalities need to hold for these
value functions that depend on the
policy which is chosen in a data
dependent way
so then the next question is okay can we
get this benchline type of inequalities
and if you have a fixed uh value
function B then you have a standard
bashing type of inequality of this type
so these are close relative so one hopes
that somehow it should be possible to
get this type of inequality from the
standard bashing type of inequality for
mdps
um and uh in fact this mdp papers are
kind of worked out uh pretty much all
the tools that we need uh to do this
um
so we want to control this
and we want to use the previous level
with this empirically Optima policy for
the offer Rewards
and uh this is the quantity that we need
to control in the benchline bond
so we have the dependence and a policy
in two places here the value function
depends on the policy and also the
kernel depends on the policy it
dependence in the kernel from the policy
can be removed by considering instead of
all state action person and proving a
uniform bond that only requires a union
Bond over the number of State actions uh
that's cheap
so we can do that so now uh we're left
with controlling this term and so that's
that's very nice because uh previously
we had this and so the only difference
to the standard bash chain bond is that
the value function that we have depends
on the random policies it's random
itself so we have to be careful with how
to deal with that the question is how to
deal with that well there was this
construction uh
by Agarwal and and co-workers from 2020
uh sham and and lean uh were on this
paper uh but they introduced this
beautiful tactic of absorbing uh mdps so
the observation is that you want to
control this deviation
at the state action pair s a
and this value function depends on the
whole of data if there were somehow
decoupled
everything would be nice so this is data
dependent this is data dependent this
depends only at the day at the data at
State action pair s a
this depends on all the data okay if we
change somehow the mdp in such a way
that this guy is not going to depend on
the data State action pair s a
then we achieved Independence because
otherwise uh the data is independent
that you obtain the different state
action pairs
so it's a decoupling tactic that they
introduced through this observing mdp
construction it's basically modifies the
mdp so that the S is something else
happens you go to a special State you
stay there you get a special reward
there it's called you and if you set
that special reward in some special way
you get exactly the value function that
you wanted to have if you're if you care
about optimal value functions so that
was their construction and uh so they
put on an Epsilon net on on these values
and all is fine for them because
everything uh Works in a nice and
lipstick way but here the problem is
that you could put an episode on that on
the possible values for this reward that
it could take
but the problem is that
you're not directly controlling with
this observing mdp construction
the value there because you solve for
the optimal policy
for that observing mdp and so that
policy changes potentially in some other
way
so that arises the need to show that
well this is just not happening so how
could this not be happening if you are
like you just need you just want to show
that you can have a fine enough grid
such that if from the grid you're
choosing the value of the reward in some
specific way and then you're optimizing
for the policy in the observing fdp then
what you get from that for one of the
values on the grid is going to be
exactly the policy that you started
the weight range for this is to uh well
visual thinking assume that there are
big action gaps if there are big action
gaps between the the action value of the
optimal action versus the action value
of all the sub-optimal actions then
smooth perturbations of the reward are
not going to change the identity of the
Optima policy you can kind of like feel
that that must be true
and so how do you arrange for Action
gaps uh you don't get action gaps for
free well except that you do if you add
random noise to the rewards then uh you
can show that that introduces this uh
controlled probability
actual gaps of a controlled size
uh just enough uh so that you can you
can arrange for a finding of grid which
still have polynomial many values such
that everything works out
so uh this technique has been worked out
in in the paper of chenley uh in this
2020 uh newspaper and so that's how they
uh had the result for the uh random
policies and we can just adapt this
technique to our setting
so what we need to do then is to add
random noise to the rewards uh set the
magnitude of this random noise not too
large not too big well if you said the
noise magnitude too large
then of course you're not solving the
original mdp so the noise magnitude
cannot be too large it has to be related
to the Precision with which you want to
solve the mdp right so it's it's a
constrained uh by the Precision so that
constrains the size of the Gap but the
size of the Gap is is not going to be
much smaller than that so it still
scarce with Epsilon and so the net is
going to have one over Epsilon uh points
on it so of all fine you suffering
logarithmic increase in Sample
complexity but but all is fine
and and the blow up in terms of the
other quantities is uh the number of
states actions and and the Horizon is
also not bad
um all right so so this is what we need
to do uh the algorithm needs to to be
changed such that in the first step you
just add small random path to basis that
you want
kind of mistakes
it it so for this we can prove uh
otherwise the algorithm is the same you
would put the same mixture policy and
for this you can uh prove this uh two
guarantees the first guarantee is for uh
the relaxed setting uh where you you
allow constraint violations you get
optimal sample complexity you also get
Optima sample complexity uh for the
strict uh setting so
that's the end all right so big open
question does the plugin based approach
work
is there a simpler proof for uh that the
cmdps basically fits constraint
variation have the same sample
complexity as normal mdps uh if uh on
the other hand no constant violation is
permitted then there is a sharp increase
in Sample complexity uh so to me the the
most interesting question is like why
does it have to be so complicated uh
there should be some simpler uh proof
but uh we are completely stuck there and
then there are lots of other interesting
questions like how to extend this to
online setting functional approximation
instances
I was wondering in a special case
suppose for my constraint all because as
you see is sensible
thank you
as far as
I mean like everything can be shifted I
think
from this perspective it doesn't matter
what range you're in
the slacker constantly
yeah
doesn't matter
foreign
that doesn't matter either yeah
right uh let's thank Java